[Musique]
al jaziras dans le sud de l'Espagne
Martin Samora est surnommé le
croque-mort des migrants
[Musique]
depuis plus de 20 ans il s'est donné une
mission
ramené auprès de leurs familles les
corps des migrants décédés en tentant la
traversée de la Méditerranée
depuis plusieurs semaines
il se bat pour ramener chez eux les
corps de trois jeunes Algériens
cet homme est né à Alger le 29 octobre
1989 il était marié c'est son frère qui
nous a donné ses informations il a
confirmé avec certitude qu'il était et
nous a précisé qu'il avait les cheveux
teints et une cicatrice due à une
récente intervention chirurgicale
la procédure de rapatriement est
compliquée car seul injuge espagnole
peut autoriser le transport des corps
une fois qu'il a la preuve irréfutable
de leur identité
s
à la police espagnole a envoyé leurs
empreintes digitales aux autorités
algériennes ce sont elles qui ont trouvé
à qui elles correspondait le juge
maintenant à tout j'attends juste à
présent qu'il valide ou non
l'identification
[Musique]
des démarches qui peuvent durer des
semaines
bon très bien pas de problème non non
vous inquiétez pas j'appellerai demain
pour voir s'il y a du nouveau écoute
toujours rien le juge est de garde mais
il est pas là aujourd'hui
les juges travaillent sur beaucoup de
dossiers à la fois alors c'est moi qui
dois me préoccuper de les relancer pour
faire avancer les choses
malgré sa détermination Martine ne
parvient pas toujours à rapatrier les
corps des migrants
dans ce cimetière il rend régulièrement
visite à ceux qu'il n'a pas pu ramener
chez eux
mais il y a les corps de 13 migrants qui
ont péri en mer en octobre 2003
alors on les a enterrés ici au cimetière
municipal
il y a peu leur corps était conservés
dans un caveau et puis on a fini par les
faire disparaître dans ce mur
c'est presque avec certitude que l'on
connaît l'identité des 13 migrants
décédés les familles ont été localisées
mais la complexité des procédures rend
le rapatriement impossible
qui ne comprenait pas pourquoi les
familles de migrants ne prenaient pas la
peine de venir en Espagne pour qu'on
prélève leur ADN je lui ai répondu
monsieur pourquoi croyez-vous que ces
gens traversent la mer dans des bateaux
fortunes vous imaginez une personne
instruite qui pose ce genre de questions
ça me laisse songeur une frustration qui
grandit avec les années
[Musique]
il y a 12 ans nous avions déjà suivi
Martin Samora au volant de son
corbillard lors du rapatriement un corps
au Maroc
pour la famille c'est très important
d'avoir leur fils à la maison même si il
est décédé
partie d'Espagne la veille c'est au
petit matin que Martine atteint enfin le
village de Sidi smile il ramène avec lui
le corps de Bouchaib un jeune homme dont
l'unique photo est celle-ci prise
lorsqu'il avait 12 ans
est décédé alors qu'il tentait de
rejoindre l'Espagne
après des semaines d'attente le village
découvre sa dépouille
pour son père le départ de bouchaïbes
est incompréhensible
[Musique]
il était conscient qu'il risquait
d'avoir des problèmes ou de finir en
prison il voulait attendre d'avoir ses
papiers c'était pour bientôt mais un
soir il est parti et je ne l'ai plus
jamais revu jusqu'au jour où on m'a
annoncé sa mort mais je l'accepte c'est
la volonté de Dieu
malgré le décès tragique de Bouchaïb de
nombreux jeunes du village nous
affirment alors qu'ils sont toujours
prêts à affronter les périls d'une
traversée clandestine de la Méditerranée
pas d'avenir je veux tenter ma chance
ailleurs
aujourd'hui la jeunesse marocaine
continue de risquer sa vie à la
recherche d'un avenir meilleur
[Musique]
en face des côtes marocaines à Cadix
Maria Lopez et médecin légiste
c'est elle que la police appelle
lorsqu'un corps est retrouvé sur la
plage
quand tu vas à la plage tu penses au
sable aux vacances à te baigner dans la
mer moi quand je vois une plage ça me
rappelle les corps de migrants échoués
chaque année Maria et son service tente
d'identifier des centaines de migrants
décédés pour la plupart ils n'ont aucun
papier d'identité
où se trouve le service de médecine
légale
c'est là qu'on autopsie les corps
retrouvés sur les plages
c'est ici à la morgue de Cadix que
commence le minutieux travail de la
médecin légiste salut Maria ça va
au dossier des migrants qui ont chaviré
oui il est dans la salle des archives
ici on a tous les dossiers des dernières
années
dans ces boîtes plus de 300 cas de
migrants non identifiés tous leurs
effets personnels sont conservés
la police m'a dit que la monnaie
marocaine n'est pas une preuve
suffisante pour connaître l'origine des
migrants on pourrait être marocain mais
aussi tout simplement de passage dans le
pays oui la monnaie c'est pas un élément
très pertinent
on a pu relever les empreintes car le
corps n'est pas resté trop longtemps
dans l'eau et sur cette photo on voit
bien comme il manque certaines dents ici
par exemple
ça nous aide beaucoup car souvent la
famille nous dit il est allé chez le
dentiste et il lui manque une molaire
une dent eau en bas tout ça ce sont des
indices mais la seule manière d'être
certain de l'identité d'une personne
c'est de relever son ADN d'obtenir son
profil génétique et de le comparer avec
celui de ses proches
dans l'attente des résultats les corps
sont conservés à la morgue parfois
plusieurs années
salut vous avez terminé l'autopsie oui
on a tout rangé
sans identification validée par le juge
le corps ne peut pas sortir d'ici si
jamais on n'arrive pas à l'identifier
alors le conserver n'a pas vraiment de
sens et
occupe de l'espace
mais la Méditerranée ne rend pas
toujours les corps
chaque année des milliers d'hommes de
femmes et d'enfants meurent sans laisser
de traces
à Madrid la Croix-Rouge a créé une
équipe pour tenter de les retrouver
rosé Pablo barré bar et le spécialiste
mondial de l'identification des migrants
disparus
je viens du bureau régional du CFR à
Paris
donner un coup de main à la courge
espagnole pour donner un regard nouveau
frais sur des vieux cas de migrants tous
ces cas sont compliqués surtout parce
que beaucoup de temps a passé seulement
de voir s'il y a quelque chose à faire
encore avec ce cas là
ce matin rosé et ses collègues se
concentre sur un groupe de jeunes
algériens dont les familles sont sans
nouvelles depuis plus d'un an on a reçu
la demande de recherche de quelqu'un qui
vit en Europe dont le frère a disparu il
nous a donné son prénom son nom et son
âge c'est un jeune adulte
c'est 12 migrants viennent tous du même
quartier et on semble-t-il embarquer au
même endroit
l'information des familles
eux peuvent nous dire simplement la
personne embarquée
et à présent on n'a pas d'informations
sur l'arrivée ok que c'est le grand
problème la question maintenant c'est
comment démontrer qu'ils sont pas
arrivés en effet
au cours de son investigation la
Croix-Rouge espagnole a pu repérer un
élément clé
une trentaine de bateaux ont échoué aux
îles Baléares et ce peu après le départ
des douches jeunes
petit bateau avec moteur 40 avant 12
personnes 12 13 personnes le premier
étape de l'enquête l'équipe appelle le
correspondant de la Croix-Rouge sur
place pour vérifier les registres des
migrants débarqués
salut Elisabeth on a besoin d'une liste
excel avec prénom nom sexe nationalité
et âge si possible des 300 migrants qui
ont débarqué on va comparer cette liste
avec les noms des 12 personnes
recherchées pour voir si elles y
apparaissent
en attendant la liste l'équipe passe au
peigne fin les contes Facebook
correspondant au nom des disparus
on peut faire une autre chose on peut
passer aux amis s'ils sont ouverts
nous apprenons que les noms des 12
migrants Algériens ne figurent pas non
plus dans les registres déballéas
alors au cas où il y a pas de corps
c'est de pouvoir dire quelque chose à la
famille
pas la personne est morte parce que pour
dire ça tu as besoin d'un corps mais au
moins dire ce qu'on a pu reconstituer de
l'événement c'est ça OK et la référence
logique c'est ça
sans Martine Maria et rosé les milliers
de migrants décédés et portés disparus
resteraient à jamais les fantômes de la
Méditerranée
[Musique]